as a talk show host I'm required to ask
you about your first jobs I'll start my
first job was driving ice cream trucks I
was a Mr Softy we're Mr Softy yeah I was
a Mr Softy Ice Cream Truck Driver oh
they would have fired me I would have
eaten all of them
it we were dropping like flies there was
like 13 of us hired to be like the
all-female contingency of Mr Softee
called Queen frosteen
I was a valet I parked cars at a at a
hotel and
um
I got I once left the keys
from another person's car
in a car that drove off for the night oh
oops so they called me at home they're
like do you have any spare keys on you
because sometimes you grab a bunch of
different keys to pull up cars in a row
I was like oh I don't like we think you
left the keys
and uh and these people had to just stay
at the hotel I don't know I somehow I
didn't get fired I was about to say that
were you
wow yeah wow the Octavia uh I worked at
a marketing research company and I
worked in the casting office did you
wear a cast injury
and the thing is I now look back and I
probably wouldn't have gotten the job
because they were they were terrified of
me I kept showing up every day
um hey if you got anything for me to do
I'm glad to do it wow and they finally
hired me oh it was like persistence
thank God I have kind eyes and not crazy
it'd be hard to turn you away wow
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
I'm going